hey I'm Matthew a tasty chef and
producer and today I'm gonna be showing
you how to make some impressive
show-stopping dinners I love beef
wellington because it's a show-stopping
dish beef wellington if a great test of
a chef it's one of the most challenging
dishes you can make I think this dish is
perfect for a special occasion so when
you sear the beef what you really want
is a dark brown crispy crust and this
process of fearing it's called the mired
reaction the mired reaction is basically
just proteins breaking down when they
reach a certain temperature and that
gives you your dark crust it's important
for great flavor and complexity with
beef so for me some of the best food
will hit on many different types of
flavors and notes and so beef wellington
kind of hit a little bit of everything
it is super meaty and savory and salty
and the mushrooms are very rich and
complex and then you have a little bit
of spice some nuance from the English
mustard that hits your nose you have
like your super buttery flaky puff
pastry so when you put a piece of beef
wellington in your mouth you have a tiny
little bit of all those flavors together
and it just smashes together perfectly
when I was 18 I left my hometown to go
to culinary school which means I'm
always away from my family except for
Christmas and New Year's and when I am
home I always make our holiday dinners
food is an expression of the heart and
this over-the-top gorgeous beef
wellington is a great way to show my
family just how much I missed them
creating show-stopping entrees it's all
about taking the time to cook for the
people you care about the dish has been
around for years and years Gordon Ramsay
was kind of the person to sort of
modernize it in a lot of ways you didn't
have to do the same duck liver pate you
didn't have to do all the old techniques
you were able to update it with stuff
like prosciutto and mustard I grew up
being a knob shaft like Dan barber
Thomas Keller Wolfgang Puck people who
really push the boundaries of what the
food world is as well as food media game
changers like James beer to enjoy a
child when I make a dish like this it
makes me feel like my idols that I grew
up loving would be impressed with what I
do and it gives me a little comfort and
gives me a lot of joy I know if I work
hard one day I'll be a major player in
the food
and I hope to become an inspiration to
other young cooks out there I like to
cook these dishes because they are a
challenge that pushed me to grow as a
chef and as a producer that tasty these
are just a tiny percentage of the food
that amazing chefs I've worked for have
taught me over the years
tasty reaches millions of people and I
want to teach them all the classics
expose them to something new and inspire
them to be adventurous in the kitchen
this is just the beginning to me cooking
is so primal innate and hands-on and
having great food is essential to having
a great life chicken marsala is a simple
dish that people get easily wowed by
this is a dish you can make on a random
Tuesday and your family or your partner
will love it there's so many dishes that
are similar to chicken marsala the
techniques in this dish are used in
thousands of other recipes it's just
about applying them to this simple dish
and mastering the technique so that the
final product is delicious what I love
about chicken marsala is that it has
very earthy flavor that comes from the
searing of the chicken and from the
mushrooms like it's nice because you can
use Marsala which is a pretty common
wine but if you don't have Marcella you
could really use any type of deep red
wine it's great to like finish off a
bottle you have at home again it's like
a really approachable dish if you do it
correctly can impress what's great about
chicken marsala is it's very like subtle
and buttery and it kind of just like
creeps up on you like if you don't cook
very often this is an easy approachable
recipe it's all about the flavor
components that you're pairing together
if you hit all the important steps
you'll have a dish that will impress
this is a great showstopping weeknight
dinner the chicken will be super
succulent and tender it will melt in
your mouth
and the creamy sauce should cling to the
pasta and chicken eventually cooking at
home will be easier for you than
ordering out also nothing is better in
this world than surprising a loved one
with a bangin weeknight dinner they
didn't expect
so with this recipe I want to be clear
I'm completely aware that this is not
traditional but I thought this would be
a cool twist on a popular Italian dish
by fusing it with a classic French dish
ratatouille is basically a tomato and
vegetable stew with lots of French herb
and lasagna is a classic Italian dish
that's been passed down through so many
families that it's eventually come over
to America when creating a show-stopping
vegetarian entree I wanted something as
satisfying and filling as a lasagna and
something that had as much vegetables as
a ratatouille the combined these two was
perfect because it took the best aspects
of a ratatouille and all of its amazing
rich flavors and it had a really great
layering aspect that came with the
Italian lasagna
neither are completely traditional
because they were put together but
that's sort of what's great about food
it's basically a universal language that
we all understand it's more exciting to
be able to learn from the best things
every country has to offer and combine
them together to make something new and
exciting that you can be thrilled to try
when I was a little kid one of the first
fusions I ever tried was combining
grilled cheese and ham I thought that
would be delicious I mean we called them
grilled Chams and now I fully realize it
was just a grilled cheese sandwich with
ham but now if that same type of
curiosity is what I take into creating
foods now to me recipes are just
guidelines the person who took the time
to write the recipe if you follow what
they do you should get the same result
that they got but that doesn't mean that
you have to if you want to experiment
and try something new you can make every
recipe your own in order to grow as a
cook you really need to take that leap
of faith and really experiment don't be
bogged down with the rules of the world
if you love two different types of
dishes combine them together make them
something new and exciting that you can
then share with your friends this is the
perfect show-stopping entree to bring to
a vegetarian friend's house or just if
you want a lighter alternative to the
rest of these media
speaking of which here the bacon-wrapped
prime rib recipe so this final recipe is
a showstopper you're gonna want to make
to give an entire crowd a cardiac arrest
for the prime rib we're doing this
reverse sear method which is the
opposite of what we did with the beef
wellington what you're doing is ensuring
that all the meat on the inside is
cooked medium-rare and then you're just
going to cook the outside at a high heat
to get that nice mired reaction and
brown bacon flavor you want
so the thought behind this dish was
basically I wanted something that was a
complete monstrosity but you were
intrigued nonetheless
and it tasted great every once in a
while people just want something that's
gonna blow their mind and that was the
goal of making this prime rib it never
fails to shock me how easily people are
impressed with good food you can make a
simple dish that just tastes great and
people act like you reinvented the wheel
so when I walk in with my food offering
I really want to blow people thumbs up I
want them to talk about the food I made
for them to their friends and nothing
impresses a crowd more than a huge piece
of meat something like this bacon wrap
prime rib is perfect for when you want
to be the winner at a party and I guess
at the end of the day that's why we all
love show-stopping food because we all
love that moment of shock and awe on
someone else's face when they just can't
wait to dive into the food you cooked
for them so growing up my family always
cooked in the kitchen I spent every
waking moment in the kitchen and I would
watch food television all the time and I
just knew I wanted to work in food my
whole life and basically knowing what
you want to do at a young age it makes
you become a huge planner it's never not
cool to be the hard worker it's never
not respected to be someone that works
hard this is what I wanted to do with my
life so I love when I make food that I
know I put time and care and love into
and I pass it off to someone else and I
just do their face light up it brings me
a lot of joy this is why every meal I
try and cook myself while I work my butt
off every day and why I try to make
every
I do be the best it can be my entire
life revolves around cooking and I love
it because it allows me to connect with
other people and tell stories through
food everyone has some favorite food
memories to tell me some of yours oh oh
yes
[Music]
[Music]